Nik is in Missouri starting off this
hour hey Nick how are you I'm good dad
are you better than I deserve what's up
that's great I need you to talk me into
spending my savings to pay off my truck
ah okay so what would your financial
goal be a long term take the house off
next and just continue to invest from
there set myself up for retirement not
everything to worry about could I
summarize that by say I'd like to become
wealthy sure okay I don't really have a
number in mind okay that's okay I'm
security till the day I die and my kids
you want to build a nest egg so you can
retire with dignity and leave an
inheritance and be generous
sure okay good those are good goals
that's that's what we teach around here
so that's perfect
well then the question becomes what is
the shortest path to that goal that's
what it that's the money to other people
yeah well you know it's and then you
start studying and say well what what if
wealthy people people that started from
nothing like you and me what did the
wealthy people do to get there and what
is the shortest path what we've
discovered over the years is is that
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and not giving it to
someone else in the form of debt is the
shortest path to building wealth now
having said all that's why you want to
pay off the houses well you won't pay
off the truck you know but you're
getting some emotional security from
this pile of money that's in your
account that you could pay off your
truck with so what do you owe on the
trunk it's just under twenty four
thousand that I own the truck okay and
how much money's and savings about yes I
have thirty three thousand okay and so
you'd have eleven thousand left if you
did this no not that yeah I'm sorry nine
thousand what if you did this
all right all right and what's your
household income after taxes combined
about fifty six a month fifty six
hundred okay all right and so you're
making about eighty-five ninety thousand
dollars a year it sounds like
between between the two of us yes yeah
that's why I'm talking about so you got
a $90,000 income I do you have any other
payments other than your house and the
truck yeah my daughter's an expensive
daycare but well that's that's not a
debt that's a monthly bill right yeah no
other debt okay all right and so if you
were doing a written budget and you and
your wife sat down and said okay if we
pay off the truck our next goal is to
make sure our emergency fund is
replenished because I'm really nervous
on the other $9,000 truck payment is how
much at 4:11 I'm in paint that kind of
month on it okay
so 600 a month for ten months would be
six to six thousand dollars and you'll
be back to 15 if you just put back into
the account only what you've been paying
on the truck and you can do smarter to
roll that into my mortgage payment no
I'd like to put myself on a no you would
build your mergency fund back up where
you have throw you to six months of
expenses once you're dead free other
than the house then I want you to start
putting 15% of your income into
retirement are you putting anything into
retirement now no I started listening to
you at the first of the year and I met
with some of your smart Bester's and got
a lot of great information there okay
but you're always hounding on paying off
debt I am and hung up on this for three
months : yes well that's okay that's
okay I'm just talking to my wife here's
the thing here's the thing the way this
feels to you is like you're gonna live
with only nine thousand dollars in your
account for the rest of your life the
way it feels to me is you're gonna live
with nine thousand dollars in your
account for it less than a year because
you're gonna have built it back up very
quickly this is not really that big a
move if you look at it that way I know
I'm just so proud of that stability
because I put my wife through college
and built a business from scratch and
lived in my truck at one point then
selfies are a lot of hard work then sell
the truck either spend the savings or
sell the truck yeah you need to make a
call well I commute 40,000 miles a year
so I have to keep the truck I guess I'm
gonna have to spin the savings well
whatever you drive you're destroying
with that many miles so doesn't matter
you're gonna be driving a high mileage
junky truck before long anyway well that
was a nice
and I had after paying off the truck
because I have to have a truck that's
able to do some pulling would it be wise
to spend two three thousand dollars on a
little gas zipper that will get me
around for a few years to make this
truck last longer uh you have to have a
truck for your job no I have an
expensive hobby and I have to drag
trailers all over the state okay all
right I don't have to I suppose it's
it's a hobby though I got you okay well
as long as you know what you're spending
on your hobby and you're okay with that
while you're doing these other goals yes
that's all part of the budget and well I
mean you're spending $25,000 on a truck
that hauls stuff six times a year that's
$3,000 a haul you could pay somebody to
do it cheaper that's twice a month but I
understand the point you're making now
either one I don't even need to really
think about it because you're destroying
a very expensive truck driving it so you
got to separate the truck decision and
the hobby has two separate decisions and
the what you're the other thing is
whatever you drive you're destroying its
value with 40,000 miles a year so I
would not be driving a nice truck and
destroy that value of that thing so yeah
if you keep it you need to get you a
$5,000 car that you destroy well because
you're putting something miles on
whatever it is and whatever you drive
becomes worthless very quickly when you
put that many miles on it because you're
a road warrior Sam you got about three
different or four different things going
on here that you've got to work your way
through the hobby separate that over
there this is what I'm willing to pay
for that hobby $25,000 of my savings so
that I have a truck to do my hobby
that's what you're saying and that's
okay but you need to say that out loud
and look at yourself in the mirror and
know you know because what amounts to is
you've been just to find the truck
saying you need that for work and you
don't need it for work you need a $5,000
car for work that's the thing our $7,000
car or something like that
so if I were in your shoes I would sell
the truck put the hobby on hold for a
little while and hit some of these
financial goals and then I'd kick my
hobby back in in a couple of years
because this hobby is taking a lot of
your money right now that's what it
sounds like but you do whatever you want
I will still be friends with you either
way we appreciate you calling